ON FRIDAY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> REPORTS OF A DIVIDE INSIDE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MODERATES FACING THREATS IF THEY
WORK WITH REPUBLICANS.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
SCOLDING MORE THAN TWO DOZEN
DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORTED A
REPUBLICAN AMENDMENT AND A GUN
CONTROL BILL.
ALG  ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
THREATENED TO PUT THEM ON A LIST
IF THEY VOTE WITH THE GOP IN THE
FUTURE.
HOW DID THEY WIN IN THE
MID-TERM?
GREG, IT WAS NOT THE LEFT.
IT WAS IN THE MODERATE SWING
DISTRICTS WHERE THEY HAVE TO
VOTE AS CONSTITUENTS WANT.
>> I LIKE HOW YOU ASKED ME THAT
QUESTION AND THEN ANSWERED IT.
I NEED TO REST MY BRAIN AFTER
BEATING JESSE ON TUCKER.
THIS TRAGEDY GIVES POWER TO THE
PEOPLE THEY ARE TRYING TO
PUNISHMENT MODERATES AND
INDEPENDENT MINDS HAVE LIKE THE
POWER OF 10 OF THEIR PEERS.
>> LIKE THE FREEDOM CAUCUS.
>> THINK ABOUT RAND PAUL.
WOULD DO YOU THIS OR THAT.
AND THE KAVANAUGH THING.
IT'S GREAT TO BE THAT PERSON.
I LOVE STALEMATES.
ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT
YOUR PARENTS FIGHTING IS THEY
OVERLOOK THE STUFF YOU ARE
DOING.
YOU COULD STAY OUT LATER AND IN
THE LIQUOR CABINENT EVERY BOTTLE
GOT SLIGHTLY LESS.
LESS WORK GETS DONE IN THE
GOVERNMENT IN STALEMATES.
IT'S A FORM OF LIMED GOVERNMENT.
>> AND THE STOCK MARKET IS
HAPPIER TOO.
WENT WOULDN'T YOU LIKED TO HAVE
BEEN A FLY ON THE WALL AT THIS
MEETING?
>> YES.
DANA, THERE IS A STATISTIC IN
SPORTS CALLED PLUS OR MINUS.
DID I JUST MAN EXPLAIN?
>> YES, AND I WELCOME IT.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE SCORING SO
MANY POINTS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
SOCIALISM AND ABOLISH I.C.E. AND
NOT TELLING ANYBODY THAT THE
ILLEGALS ARE TRYING TO BUY GUNS.
IF THE DEMOCRATS LOSE THE HOUSE
IN 2020, THERE WILL BE DEMOCRATS
POINTING THEIR FINGER AT AOC.
ON TOP OF THAT WANTS TO CREATE A
CIVIL WAR?
SHE IS LIKE THE STEVE BANNON OF
THE LEFT?
YOU GET SOME GOOD CANDIDATES AND
THEN YOU GET AIKENS AND CRAZY
PEOPLE.
CHRISTINA THE WITCH.
>> I AM NOT A WITCH.
>> I LOVE WHEN DEMOCRATS FIGHT
EACH OTHER.
SIT BACK AND RELAX.
>> LOOK AT THIS POLL, KENNEDY.
THIS IS WAS IN THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
A QUESTION ABOUT MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
IN 2018 THERE WAS 30% SUPPORT.
TODAY 12%.
>> A HELL OF A CHART, DANA.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
CHART?
>> IT'S A GREAT CHART.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE ISSUES RATHER THAN JUST
ABOUT PERSONALITIES.
>> THAT'S FANTASTIC.
THE PROBLEM IS PROGRESSIVES THEY
FEEL THE PERSONALITY WILL SELL
THE IDEA.
VOTERS ARE MORE TUNED-IN THAN
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT
POLITICS NOW DAYS.
ONE.
MY BOSSES POINTED OUT THIS IS
THE NEW WATER COOLER.
IT USED TO BE THE KARDASHIANS
AND NOW IT'S PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
CONGRESS.
PEOPLE GO WAIT A SECOND.
WHAT DOES THIS COST?
MARIE AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS.
MODERATE DEMOCRATS WHO MADE IN
ROADS IN THE PARTY AND NANCY
PELOSI AND AOC A NEW
CONGRESSWOMAN IS TELLING THEM
THEY HAVE TO VOTE IN LOCK STEP.
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL BE
POPULAR BACK HOME?
NO WAY!
IF THEY THROW OFF THE BLOB AND
SHOW INDEPENDENCE THEY ARE MORE
ELECTABLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD WANT THIS
JOB IS.
IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE TELLING YOU
IF YOU DON'T VOTE A CERTAIN WAY,
YOU ARE GOING ON A LIST?
THAT'S A HORRIBLE JOB.
>> AND ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
AND HER LIST, AND TORRES SMALL
ALSO A FRESHMAN WON IN NEW
MEXICO.
SHE STOOD UP AND SAID YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO RUN IN A
DISTRICT -- OBVIOUSLY AOC BEAT
THE INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT.
>> DEMOCRAT ARE SEEING WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS WENT THROUGH AND
STILL SEEING IT.
YOU HAVE HARD-CORE RIGHT
WING-FOLKS.
MODERATE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T RUN
IN 2018 BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT
THAT INTER-PARTY PRIMARY.
I DON'T THINK THESE MODERATE
DEMOCRATS WILL CALL LOCK STEP IN
LINE WITH AOC AND I DON'T THINK
AOC SUPPORTING PRIMARY
CHALLENGERS WILL WORK.
IF WE LOOK AT THE MODERATE
STATES IN 2018 THE DEMOCRATS
THAT WON THE PRIMARIES WERE
MODERATES.
LOOK AT VIRGINIA.
TOM PROGRESSIVE, HE LOST.
>> I BET YOU WISH THE OTHER GUY
HAD WON.
>> GILLESPIE?
NO, I DON'T WISH THAT.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING
DISCUSSION.
I THINK THAT AOC IS GOOD AT
GETTING PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT
HER.
THE QUESTION THAT WILL FACE
VOTERS.
.
WHO HAS DONE SOMETHING FOR YOU?
THE MODERATE DEMOCRATS HAVE
PLANS TO SAY HERE IS HOW I TRIED
TO HELP YOU.
SHE IS GETTING SO MUCH GRIEF
FROM INSIDE THE PARTY FOR
THREATENING THE PRIMARY PEOPLE
WHICH SHE HASN'T DONE ANYTHING
IN CONGRESS.
>> I CAN ADD SOMETHING?
TALKING ABOUT MODERATE
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE COMING UP
WITH IDEAS TO PUSH FORWARD AN
AGENDA WHICH IS THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IS
DOING IN THE HOUSE.
THEY DON'T HAVE IDEAS.
THEY HAVE RESISTANCE.
>> LET ME GRAB THIS OTHER TOPIC.
JOE BIDEN FORCED TO APOLOGIZE
AFTER MAKING THIS STATEMENT
ABOUT MIKE PENCE.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
THE GUY IS A DESCENT GUY.
DECENT GUY.
OUR VICE-PRESIDENT.
-- HE STOOD BEFORE THIS GROUP OF
ALLIES AND E
ALLIES AND LEADERS AND SAID I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THERE WAS DEAD SILENCE.
>> TONS OF BACK LASH FOR CALLING
PENCE A DECENT GUY.
HE BACK TRACKED.
GREG?
>> YOU CAN BELIEVE THAT PENCE IS
INCORRECT IN HIS BELIEFS AND
STILL SEE BIDEN AS A REALLY WEEK
PERSON.
HE FOLDED TO A MOB ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
IF HE GETS THAT EASILY SPOOKED
WHICH IS THE OPPOSITE OF BEING A
LEADER, HOW WOULD HE HANDLE THE
TWITTER MOM OR EVEN TRUMP IN A
DEBATE?
IF YOU FOLD THAT QUICKLY.
JOE SHOULD HAVE SAID, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
PENCE WAS WHERE I WAS 15 YEARS
AGO.
DO I DISLIKE WHO I WAS 15 YEARS
AGO?
NO, I THOUGHT I WAS A GOOD GUY
AND STILL THINK HE IS A GOOD
GUY.
ONE RELIGION GETS THE SHAFT AND
ANOTHER RELIGION DOESN'T INTO
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
IF JOE BIDEN SAID A LEADERSHIP
POSITION, NUMBER 2 ISSUE IN THE
COUNTRY IS WORRY ABOUT
POLARIZATION, TO BE A LEADER AND
SAY WE ARE ALL AMERICANS.
>> WE CAVED TO THE RESISTANCE.
YOU KNOW MY MOTO?
NEVER APOLOGIZE.
IT MAKES YOU LOOK WEAK AND SOFT.
>> THE ART OF THE JESSE.
>> YES.
>> IN 2020, IT WILL BE THE
DEMOCRATS TO WHO APOLOGIZE FOR
EVERYTHING AND TRUMP WHO
APOLOGIZES FOR NOTHING.
JOE BIDEN WAS A DECENT MAN WHEN
HE THE SAME POSITION ON
TRADITIONAL MARRIAGE.
IT DIDN'T MAKE YOU ANTI-LBGTQ.
DIDN'T THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
JUST PUSH FOR A WORLD-WIDE
DECRIMINALIZE
DECRIMINALIIZATION OF HOME
SEXUALITY?
>> VOTERS CARE ABOUT DIFFERENT
THINGS THAN THE ON-LINE TWITTER
MOMS.
THEY CAN'T SUCK UP THEIR TIME
AND ENERGY, GETTING TIED INTO
THE MOB AND RESPONDING TO
EVERYTHING.
BUT LOOK AT ISSUES LIKE
ELIZABETH WARREN AND THE
NATIVE-AMERICAN ISSUE.
VOTERS ARE NOT ASKING HER ABOUT
THAT.
>> I THINK GREG AND MARIE HAVE
IT.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> NEVER APOLOGIZE.
>> OH!
>> OUCH!
>> YOU CAN'T FOLD TO THE MOB.
YOU CAN'T ANTICIPATE THEM AND
YOU CAN'T PASSIFY THEM.
SO DON'T EVEN TRY.
THIS ELECTION WILL BE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN 2016.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO DECIDE, DO
THEY WANT A CHEAP PALE
IMPRESSION OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND SLING INSULTS?
OR DO THEY WANT SOMEONE WHO IS
STRONG AND CAN LEAD THE COUNTRY.
SOMETIMES BEING STRONG MEANS I
AM NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS EVERY TIME I